heute miteinander und willkommen zu der
q&ay zum Reportage work-life Dilemma
Spagat zwischen Karriere und
Lebensqualität setzt sehr viel
kommentarge danke viel viel mal es ist
auch mega interessant Thema und ja ihr
seid ja wir können Gardine mit kommen
work free time Balance weil für die
meisten Arbeit zum Leben dazugehört yes
aber ähm ich habe der Begriff Work Life
Balance in der Reportage und auch im
Titel will etwas wo der Meister Lied
kennen und sofort wissen um das Gott
aber eigentlich ist ja eher Banner
zwischen aussieht und Freizeit das wäre
sehr korrekt also du absolut Recht eure
Erfahrungen zu dem ganzen Thema true
perplexus schreibt ich finde es sehr
wichtig dass ich unsere Generation
überlegt wie viel wir arbeiten wollen
zumal der Stress am Arbeitsplatz immer
mehr zunehmen hey ja das finde ja und
das ist auch genau der Grund wieso die
Reportage gemacht hat will sich relativ
viel momentan viel Gedanken um das Thema
machen und will auch relativ viel in
Bewegung ist in der Arbeitswelt wir
schafft man richtig gut noch besser als
dass man schon schafft seine Nummer mit
Effizienz Store also wir schaffen mal
schneller und effiziente sondern auch
wir schaffen es besser im sinnvoll wie
Gott der Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter langfristig gut oder nur
besser als jetzt also deshalb finde ich
super wichtig dass man darüber reden und
deshalb ist
da achtet auf Warnsignale und verdrängt
sie nicht wie ich und schont euren
Körper ich habe nur einen Jobs gibt es
genug und geld alleine macht euch auch
nicht wieder gesund ja ich glaube das
kommt jetzt in das eine wo halt ihre
Stimme man kann aber bevor ich nur für
was und das hätte mehrere Kommentar sie
zum Beispiel ich bin gerade in meinem
heftigen Burnout weil ich in dem
vergangenen 22 Jahre alt Jahren den
Bogen weiter entspannt habe die Arbeit
Politik in den deutschsprachigen Ländern
ist eher problematisch ja und genau
wegen dem ist so wichtig dass man sich
über das Thema Gedanken machen dass mir
einmal drüber reden hey ist das eine gut
dass man da machen jeder Tag acht
Stunden am Tag oder sollte man das
vielleicht nicht irgendwie anders argum
der Martin
nur daran denken wer reduziert arbeitet
sich um eigene Investments kümmern und
die Lücke in der Pensionskasse zu
schließen ja das ist vor allem wichtig
wenn man wirklich tiefprozentige schafft
also ich glaube mit 80 90 Prozent ist
glaube noch nicht das Thema aber wenn
man dann wirklich 50 60% können wir
vorstellen vor allem die Eltern wird
desto größer Kraft so Lücken den
Pensionsalter das ehrlich gesagt eine
Kasse Sekunde denkt bis der
kommentarisch interessant
wird viel über alte und junge gesprochen
aber er hat wann ist man alt 30 60 90
also ab 29 gehabt alt klar ich arbeite
hundert Prozent plus am Samstag 6
Stunden Teilzeitjob mach es auch schon
acht Jahre so bin voll happy kommt immer
darauf an was man im Leben will und wie
schnell man sich zufrieden gibt solange
man noch gesund ist warum nicht yes
irgendwie stimmt es solange gesund ist
hey go for it vor allem wenn Bock drauf
hast aber er war das Champions
wichtig zum achtsam gern Schaffer ich
gehöre zu der erwähnten älteren
Generation und ich werde mein
Unternehmen und meine Arbeit machen bis
ich in der Kiste liege aber ich mache es
gerne und arbeitestiere auch ein Hobby
ja was soll ich doch dazu sagen mein
macht vielleicht mal Ferien aber solange
du glaubst
bis 100
bis 720 gewinnen möchte schwanger
Fernsehen machen also das wäre so mein
Wunsch
total in der Balance wenn ich so lange
Zeit kam zu mir beim Selina Susan
Schritt naja ist die Generation von uns
wirklich so kaputt über das Rede noch
mit der Carolin wo auch in der Reportage
Völker ist ganz am Anfang
tiktok und der bei social media content
macht für die Pflanze Firma Caroline
also du zahlst dir der Generation ist so
kaputt
[Musik]
nehmen solche Sachen also Leute die
wirklich lange gearbeitet haben sind ja
wesentlich anfälliger für Leute die
jetzt gleich noch relativ frisch auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt sind da muss ich natürlich
nicht jeder angesprochen fühlen es sind
ja es sind ja auch einige wenige
Führungspersonen die sowas entscheiden
könnte der nur 15 Mensch der natürlich
keinen Einfluss drauf wie hoch jetzt der
Arbeitsdruck auch ist sondern die
meisten von uns sind ja eh Angestellte
die da nicht mit zu reden haben im
Endeffekt das ist ja auch ein bisschen
Luxus oder wenn du einen Job hast wo du
kannst dich das so frei ist
viele Unternehmer wo da viel strenger
sind oder viel weniger Kulanz ja was
willst du was willst du denn deine
Empfehlung also Ehre Unternehmer wieso
sollte man ähm der lügt mehr Freiheit
gehe oder respektive
glaube wenn der
Arbeitgeber sowas nicht respektiert und
da auch kein offenes Ohr für hat dass er
seine Angestellten im Endeffekt
verbrennt ich glaube dass der Trend auch
gerade in mit den jüngeren Leuten dazu
führt dass die Leute auch schneller
einfach gehen wenn sie sagen hier
gefällt mir nicht oder hier bin ich
nicht glücklich so kann ich nicht leben
und ich glaube dass es einfach dazu
führt dass man das einige Unternehmen
dann sehr sehr schnell wechselnde
Angestellte haben das wird da
problematisch werden würde ich behaupten
ich glaube das ist einfach der
die der Zukunft oder die Zukunft wird so
aussehen dass eben genau auf die
Probleme der Angestellten eingegangen
werden muss aber was sie jetzt so als
Gegenargument Chöre am nichts oder mehr
denke ich so oh mein Gott es sind alles
weiche
knackiges Problem ist was auch wirklich
zu körperlichen Beschwerden oder
psychischen Beschwerden führt dann kann
man halt nicht sagen weil ich ja sondern
dann ist es denn dieses dieses Weichei
Argument ist ja denn wie eine
Verdrängung des das eigentlichen
Problems und man es wird zu keiner
Lösung führen da kann man noch 30 mal
sagen Weichei das Weichei wird ein
weicher bleiben und Probleme haben
schreibt wenn du liebst was du tust
kannst du 7 Tage die Woche 12 Stunden
lang arbeiten ja klar
Hobbys machen mir Spaß weil ich sie
ausleben kann wann ich möchte sobald ich
mein Hobby zum Beruf mache dann kann
auch das Hobby noch so lustig gewesen
sein irgendwann kommt man dann in so
einen Zwang und sobald es an Zwang geht
wird unlustig und ich glaube dass man
dass es auch ganz normal ist dass man
wenn man eine Arbeit gefunden hat die
einen wirklich Spaß macht dass die am
Anfang richtig richtig dolle Spaß macht
und dann kommt man automatisch in so ein
Tief wo es nicht mehr so viel Spaß macht
und wo man dann halt sich einpendeln
muss auch zwischen Pflichten und
dem was einem halt Spaß macht und dass
ich das dann irgendwann so auspendelt so
ein bisschen
Carolin danke vielmal für die Zeit und
alles Gute es hätte paar Kommentare geht
zu der Protagonisten und protagonistine
Wahl oder respektive zum Ort wo ihr
gegangen ich finde es ist ja opportunity
verpasst worden dazu mit lidräder im Job
wo wirklich viel scharf also gern mal
regelmäßig 16 bis 18 Stunden am Tag
Ernst Management Consultants
Investmentbanking oder auch mir fehlt in
diese Reportage die sich
Mitarbeiterinnen auf dem Bau oder Kita
Betreuerinnen sanitärinnen
Pflegepersonal das stimmt also wir haben
andere Jobs our clockt für die Reportage
und immer über Leitern hey was soll ich
machen was soll ich Anna
Pflegepersonal
will mir schon Reportage gemacht hat zu
dem Thema kürzlich also ich glaube im
Mai ist dir record Kanal absoluten
Fehler ich hätte gern ein bisschen
Consulting und Investmentbanking zum
Beispiel gemacht Video wirklich
tatsächlich sehr krasse
Arbeitszeiten aber das Ding ist einfach
dass ich visuell nicht spannend und
schlussendlich machen Video und Filme
wenn er 16 Stunden
gemacht aber es ist tatsächlich im Kopf
sie und in der Kommentare jetzt noch
mehrere inspirierende Sachen geben wo
man könnte für nächste Reportage
aufnehmen auf meine Thema Listen notiert
Salatsoße sehr schöner Name schreibt ich
finde den Vergleich mit den Spitzensport
gesehen sehr gut ich finde nicht dass
etwas dagegen spricht ein Workaholic zu
sein solange es einem so fühlt ich hatte
wirklich mit der Hochleistungssportlerin
oder mit Athleten
mit 120 nur max Schaffer das heißt es
ist nicht auch nachhaltige Art und wir
Hochleistungssport
war wenn es für sie stimmt dann ist das
okay das ist der Quintessenz sowieso
Reportage für alles stimmt du bist total
anders und das ist auch okay so und das
muss wunderbar einfach
oder über den nächsten Schritt ein
bisschen Interessantes über mich ähm was
sollen diese ganzen englische Begriffe I
can do it ich glaube 68 englische
Begriff Buch das tut mir leid
unterwegs bin hanna hat nicht wirklich
escript will mir einfach du Haus um
erstellen die Frage wo der Moment in
Sinn kommt mir sagen das wo gerade ich
beschäftigt in dem Moment und den Gott
hat bei miramix unter zum super
Schritt mir scheint es dass der Reporter
seine Arbeit liebt oder bilde ich mir
das nur ein nein das stimmt und da
wieder halt aber es ist okay wenn ich
viel über Sachen noch denke wenn ich
mich fest mit dem identifiziere für mich
stimmt das das ist sie von der Region da
ich danke viel mal dass du Glück hast
bis zum Schluss falls du jetzt und noch
gar nicht Reportage reden sie doch noch
mal verlinkt und ja das ist sie nächste
Woche geht's neu Reck Reportage und mir
gesehen das nächste Mal wieder